all right i am a dan st professor here
in the school of Forestry and
environmental studies as well at the el
as the yale law school i am also the
director of the Yale Center for
Environmental Law and Policy that is a
co-sponsor of today's program I'm the
former director of the world fellows
program that is the other co sponsor of
today's program and it is a great
pleasure to have with us today for of
the Yale world fellows of recent vintage
who have insights on the environmental
arena and who are going to share with us
their perspectives on the road to
Copenhagen and the prospects for a
beyond Kyoto new climate change
agreement and we do gather at an
auspicious moment in that regard it's
about six weeks from now that the
world's leaders will be in Denmark
hoping to put or they had hope to put
the finishing touches on a new climate
change agreement I will predict for you
now that we will not get a full-blown
new agreement to go beyond the Kyoto
Protocol I think that's not a difficult
prediction at this point but it is a sad
one and I do think we want to ask our
panelists today to comment on both the
prospects for Copenhagen and what it
would take to get my prediction
overturned but also what plan B looks
like where we go if we don't get to
Copenhagen with the prospects of a big
new deal by the way I think we should
all watch out for the prospect of there
being a kind of a happy face put on what
comes out of Copenhagen in fact I like
to tell the story of Morris strong who
was the secretary general of the 1992
Earth Summit in Rio de Janeiro and I was
at the time working for the u.s.
government and remember Mora strong
taking me aside and you know i'd asked
him what the outcome he expected was and
he said there's only two outcomes
possible when you bring so many of the
world's leaders together he said there's
the possibility of success
and the possibility of real success and
I think when you do gather so many folks
it's often the case that people want to
declare success whether or not they have
actually achieved it and I suspect that
will be the case in Copenhagen but
perhaps we can press our panel as well
on what real success would look like
coming out of this negotiation in
December we have as I said a superb
panel and I'm going to introduce all
four of them at the outset and then just
pass the baton down the line here and
give each of them a chance to make an
opening statement and then we'll really
try to turn this into a conversation as
quickly as possible with you all asking
questions and you can ask anyone or all
of the panelists to respond and we'll
try to get some debate and dialogue
going back and forth so on my immediate
left to the right as you all look at us
is Sasha Muller Crenna he is the
managing director and European
representative of the Nature Conservancy
he has a past set of experiences in the
environmental arena that are both broad
and deep he's a was one of the founders
of the most important environmental
think tank in Germany the ecologic
Institute he also served as the bold
foundations representative for Europe
director for Europe as well as the
director for North America which gave
him a period of time based in Washington
DC he comes out of the Green Party
politics in Germany and has spent a
great deal of his life looking at not
just German environmental issues but
global scale ones so we'll welcome his
views in just a moment next to sasha is
tim jarvis he's an Australian an
associate director of a company called
urs based in the UK and he works in this
regard as an environmental scientist
advising developing countries on how to
achieve sustainability on how to manage
their natural resources in an
appropriate way how to deal with
contaminated land how to address the
energy push that they're facing in the
need for energy efficiency he's perhaps
even better known as an explorer he's
been to both the North and South Poles
and has produced some extraordinary
documentary films
based on those expeditions next to him
is hidden bromberg from israel hidden
his director of something called eco
peace and also friends the earth middle
east he's had that role for 15 years and
he is especially known for trying to
bridge divides it comes from a region
where that kind of bridge building is
critical and he has done it with
innovative methods looking at
environmental issues and has built a
network not just in Israel but across
the Middle East that is seeking to think
about how to bring environmental
progress and peace and better
understanding across countries and
finally we have Vince Paris of the
Philippines Vince is a former energy
minister of the Philippines he was a
banker in his earlier life he is
currently the chair of World Wildlife
Fund Philippines and is also working
today as a CEO of a company called alt
energy partners which is a renewable
electric power company looking to build
renewable energy projects across Asia so
a very interesting mix of perspectives
and I hope hearing across these
different viewpoints will get some
illumination on the path to Copenhagen
so let me start with Sasha take it away
so they have to push a button the
Elledge know everyone's everyone's
hearing me so first thanksgiving for the
invitation to you into the program and I
see this is an issue everyone seems to
be interested in I gave another talk
this today about noon where there were
as many people in the audience as we
have on the panel here something I got
on the general elections but climate
change seems to be something everyone
wants to hear about and but you already
some develop the trust prospects for
Copenhagen are are not as good as we
would have wished for two years ago when
we set out on the road to Copenhagen at
the UN conference in Bali 90 2007 and I
also think the alternative in Copenhagen
is whether we will have have an
agreement or whether we will have a good
agreement this is in fact the danger
that
what we should be looking for is
something that I would call an ambitious
outcome we probably will not get out of
Copenhagen with a new treaty that will
replace the Copenhagen the Kyoto
Protocol but we should get out with a
political deal that puts it on a puts us
on a road towards such an agreement and
what I want to present here is a view
from Europe also little bit obviously
view from myself on the Nature
Conservancy and what the European you
need once in those negotiations is
basically well fill the gaps of the
Kyoto Protocol and built on the elements
of the Kyoto Protocol that should be
retained so filling the gaps of the
Kyoto Protocol basically means two
things first there should be a new
commitments for developed countries
especially for those developed countries
that are not part of the Cure the
protocol and this is mainly the United
States killer was ratified by a number
of countries but the biggest emitter
worldwide which is the United States has
not joined to cure the protocol and
everyone in EU agrees that it does not
make sense to negotiate a new agreement
that does not include us and that points
to the lack of political process here on
the domestic front there is no climate
change legislation here yet in the
United States coming out of Congress and
the US administration has made it
perfectly clear that there will be no
commitment of the US government in
international negotiations before the
legal basis here domestically has been
has been established to enter into a
commitment both for reductions but also
for financial support for developing
countries but this is element number one
that we have new and stronger
commitments for developed countries that
at least get close to what science what
the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change recommends for us and us that in
aggregate for all developed countries
would have to be something like 25 to 40
percent greenhouse gas emission
reductions by the year twenty twenty
based on 1990 levels so the second gap
of Kyoto is not the US but it's that a
lot of developing countries have
ratified the Kyoto
protocol including the big emerging
economies like China India Brazil
Indonesia but without having any
significant commitments going along with
that so a new agreement coming out from
Covent Copenhagen that is the clear view
of European governments has to contain
in has to include to clear commitments
for developing countries to those must
not be fixed reduction commitments
nationwide economy-wide reduction
commitments like for the Europeans the
Americans Australians or the Japanese
but it must be something like a staying
or staying in a quantifiable and
measurable way under business as usual
scenarios which are as you are now
outright scary when you look at where
the Chinese emissions are going when you
look at where forest emissions from
Brazil and Indonesia are going and so on
and so forth so there must be something
quantifiable and measurable measurable
commitments coming from China whether
it's for the overall economy or whether
it's at least for specific sectors like
in targets for increasing energy
efficiency the share of renewables of a
specific economic sectors like the steel
industries the cement industry and so on
and so forth and there is obviously a
balance between what developed countries
what the EU will put on the table what's
developing countries will put on the
table so what we wants to retain from
hero is some of the political
innovations it's the first legally
binding climate change agreement that
we've ever had it contains reduction
commitments at least for a number of
countries and it has established a
number of interesting mechanisms to
reach those reductions for example
emission trading it has not established
a global carbon market but it has laid
the ground for a number of emerging
regional carbon markets the European
carbon market has been the first step
it's already working since several years
it slowly being improved and the screws
are tightened but in a lot of other
places including cap-and-trade
legislation that is being discussed in
the US Senate right now but also in
Japan and Australia carbon markets are
slowly being established and this is a
this is one of the key in a way
of the Kyoto Protocol and we want to
retain the framework the same for the
Clean Development the mechanism and
other innovations like that in addition
to that what we need to get out of
Copenhagen very clearly is we also have
to include some of the elements that
were not considered in in Kyoto the
first one is forests forest globally
contributes twenty percent to to the
emissions tropical deforestation
especially we have to include forest
they also have to be twenty percent of
the solution we have to include
adaptation this was not a big issued 15
years ago it's now a major issue for the
majority of countries at least
especially for the least developed
countries and small island states and we
have to take care of financing all this
will mean that a lot of money will flow
from A to B from developed or developing
countries for forests for adaptation for
technology transfer and that money by
the way can only come out of global
carbon markets and by the way when
setting up cap-and-trade legislation
here in the US this is also something to
look at that the auctioning of the
emission permits also generates those
revenues well you already said
Copenhagen will probably not reduce such
an agreement I agree nevertheless to get
to a political deal a political
declaration by than maybe such a roadmap
for the next six to 12 months after
Copenhagen still some hurdles have to be
overcome and there are not that many
opportunities for world leaders to to
meet in the coming weeks and get those
things done and in fact this can only be
done on the leaders level this is
nothing that can be sorted out on the
diplomats level or even by environment
ministry's but only on the highest level
because there will be all those
trade-offs with trade policy economic
policy even foreign security policy
considerations the only health of state
can do that now there is only one major
opportunity where a critical mass of
heads of state will meet which is the
APEC summit mid-november in Bangkok so
the Asian leaders will go there mr.
Putin and mr. Medvedev he'll go there
mr. Obama and European leaders have
already announced that if the US and if
others are willing to do it they would
do as leaders summit before a Copenhagen
to
cut that deal so I hope this works out
there will be the European summit end of
this week and immediately after the
summit Chancellor methyl reelected today
by German parliament for four more years
will go to Washington until give a
speech to both house Congress so I hope
she will come with a strong message from
European leaders she already has dinner
with mr. sarkozy right now so I hope
they they come an agreement here and
send a clear message from Europe to the
US administration that we need this
breakthrough on the highest level and in
closing let me come back to again to the
Morris Chung quote after you're
imagining so my my scenario my man
negative scenario is not that the
negotiations will break down and this
can happen it can well happen that
developing countries in Copenhagen will
say well considering that the US has not
put anything on the table we just walk
out or that the African countries Walker
this is a scenario that is possible
although I don't think it's likely
because so much has been invested into
this summit so many world leaders go
there and everyone wants to show a
successor tell so the real danger is a
cover up the real danger is that leaders
will pass in non-binding political
declaration without any substance and
that we will get into something like we
have in the trade area with a doe her
trade around that since years we are
pretending we're having international
talks but they lead nowhere and what
we're having in fact is a lot of
bilateral deal making and the aggregated
quality of those deals is much below
what we would have had in a new trade
regime and what we will have in the
climate regime again will be much below
what we could have had as part of an
international treaty and definitely
below what we need as science tells us
thank you so I should thank you very
much and with a provocative thought that
a flaming failure would be better than a
false success I happen to agree with
that so it's a point we should debate a
couple of housekeeping notes before I go
on to Tim any of you who are sitting on
the sides are in the back there are
seats up front please come take a seat
if you'd like we're eager to have
everyone be comfortable second of all we
are
recording this event today so any of you
who would not come you know you're far
from your home newspaper but any of you
who who are not interested in being
recorded should take this opportunity to
depart otherwise we have presumed your
acquiescence in the in being on film if
you happen to have the camera passed by
you there will also be a reception
outside afterward when we're done we're
going to run for just about fifty five
more minutes and hopefully cover a lot
of ground in that time so we've had the
European view let's get the view from
down under and perhaps even more broad
than that Tim yeah thank you Dan I'm
going to just talk very briefly about a
little bit of background what I
personally seen I'm an environmental
auditor so I get to see things at the
kind of pointy end of industry in other
words one industries putting up the
stacks into the atmosphere for my sins I
walk around in the polar regions five
times three times the South Pole and
twice up north so i get to see at the
receiving end of the the equation what's
going on and i also work in the aid
sector in asia pacific where I see you
know sea level rise and the threat of it
is a real issue for a lot of the Pacific
island communities with whom I with whom
I deal very brief synopsis without going
into the IPCC fourth assessment report
with a very learned audience we have
obviously a range of co2 emissions
scenarios with a corresponding array of
climate temperature increased scenarios
and a corresponding array of sea level
rise scenarios I'm not going to kind of
go into into those but what I would say
in the context of the polar regions you
have three fundamental things going on
up north you have the melting of the
Greenland ice cap which is contributing
perhaps 250 cubic kilometers a year into
the
the global sea levels you have the
melting of the Arctic sea ice which if
you're trying to walk to the North Pole
makes things extremely tricky given that
you have to walk across that surface of
frozen ocean in order to make that
journey possible the the impact that's
having it's only 15 feet thick at the
North Pole itself the ice in the event
of its melting along the rest of the ice
that covers the surface of the Arctic
Ocean you're going to end up with a lot
more incoming heat which currently is
reflected back out into space being
absorbed by the ocean the Arctic Ocean
and having a corresponding positive
feedback on on on warming temperatures
and disruption of global circulations
oceanic circulations and that kind of
thing the third thing you have happening
up there of course is this massive
positive feedback nightmare scenario of
the methane emissions from Siberia we've
meet name being perhaps 20 times more
potent as a greenhouse gas than co2 of
course you've got areas the size of
France bubbling away up north has been a
lot of time in Siberia witnessed a lot
of this kind of stuff myself firsthand
in terms of down south the majority of
Antarctica is not melting however the
Western Antarctic camp which extends far
further north than me the larger eastern
cap does does or is experiencing a large
number of problems we've had a series of
fatty cataclysmic losses of ice shelves
and things like that Larsen B being the
most famous example fairly recently five
six years ago and it is a real issue
there and and and just to put things in
perspective the Western cap on its own
could raise global sea levels by seven
meters with all of the corresponding
impacts on population migration and
disease and some you know salinity
issues for freshwater aquifers and that
kind of thing so that's the sort of
scenario as to what I've seen personally
in the polar regions in terms of trying
to put more of a tangible face to this
idea of trying to restrict emissions to
450 parts per million or more recently
there's been a drive to restrict things
to 350 with a view to getting a 2 degree
C temperature cap to put that into more
real terms I looked at the world energy
councils predictions as to what the
total reserves of coal gas and oil were
currently and the figure is around 800
billion tons of carbon equivalent stored
in those reserves now based on
multipliers if we were to burn all of
that lot we have about three trillion
tons of co2 contributed into the
atmosphere if you look at a couple of
reports in nature recently report by a
guy called Allan he said really we want
to be limiting our total carbon dioxide
emissions into the atmosphere to about
1.8 trillion tons by the year two
thousand five hundred in order to have
any chance of keeping temperatures
temperatures at 2 degrees C a guy called
mines house and said between the years
2000 and 2050 we really want to be
keeping the figure at 1 trillion tons
now given that we're putting 30 billion
tons a year into the atmosphere as a
global collective and we're already ten
years into mine thousands fifty year
time period we're already unfortunately
well on the way to the Ln buell 1
trillion tons about 300 billion tons
into that one trillion now most of the
scenarios we have to try and reduce co2
emissions upon which the Copenhagen
discussion will be the latest
opportunity to talk about don't get it
anywhere near those kind of scenarios
what I wanted to just finish on briefly
is is the kind of message that Australia
and the UK I wear two hats I have two
passports Australian and British what
their respective positions on this
situation what the message is that that
sends to the other people at the
copenhagen conference in the case of
australia australia is the largest coal
exporter in the world by 2020 we will
still rely extremely heavily on coal as
our principal energy generating power
source about 75% we expose export as I
say most most Coulter China we have
virtually no solar update when you
compare it with the country like Germany
who has a very very good track record in
the year of solar uptake we have an
extremely strong cold body we have a
Labour government that was elected in
basically on the back of the manifesto a
green manifesto
and thus far we've put back our cap and
trade scheme not one year but now two
years and we've moved the baseline date
from which we're going to try and reduce
emissions by from 1990 to the year 2000
so we're we're looking now instead of
reducing from a 1990 baseline we look at
a year 2000 baseline instead of getting
the schema in 2009 we're now pushing
back to 2011 that's not to my mind the
kind of message you want to send when
you're going into something like
Copenhagen take the Brits the Brits
apparently have showered themselves in
glory with this this fantastic
commitment to reducing co2 emissions the
largest commitment that any country has
made by eighty percent of 1990 levels by
2050 but if you look at the reality
what's actually being achieved on the
ground we're really well off track in
terms of achieving anything significant
if you look at the twelve percent
reductions that the UK has so far
managed to achieve against 1990 baseline
the latest thinking is that perhaps a
third of that is due to carbon credit
purchase and perhaps a third of that is
due to recessionary downturn and a
natural if you want to call it that
reduction in the amount of co2 that
we're putting in the atlases because of
an industry industrial downturn in terms
of some of the institutional barriers we
have all sorts of great commitments as I
say that but when it comes to really
rethinking for example the introduction
of a significant quantity of nuclear
into the UK power mix we only have 12
functioning nuclear power stations at
the present time eight of those are
going to be offline in the early 2020s
we've spent a lot of time and energy
trying to reduce the planning time that
it takes to actually get new nuclear
power stations up and running which is a
great initiative but on the flip side
the Scots are not at all interested in
having nuclear power stations in their
home turf and we haven't really done the
numbers properly in terms of what the
cost would actually be get these things
up and running and quite frankly we're
really running out of time to get a lot
of those power stations up and running
commissioned and producing electricity
and putting it back in
agreed to contribute to our co2
reduction significantly by the year
twenty twenty so a lot of talk but not
in my mind tremendous amount of action
taking the recessionary the natural
recessionary losses out of the equation
and the carbon credits out of the
equation we perhaps realize to four
percent reduction on 1990 levels to
where we're at currently now again we're
not talking to two uninformed people at
Copenhagen they know exactly what the
numbers are even under the most basic
analysis as to where the UK currently is
so we can't go in there all guns blazing
saying look we're committing to eighty
percent reductions in 1990 levels by
2050 what about you because
unfortunately the numbers just just
don't add up so from where I'm standing
and I personally personally am a bit
ashamed of Australia's efforts in this
area we are virtually the largest
excluding some of the small United Arab
Emirates countries the largest per
capita emitter of carbon in the world
certainly far higher than the u.s. if we
really expect countries like India and
China to come to the party which they're
not really legally bound to do we need
to really be demonstrating some serious
some serious moves in the right
direction in order to get them to want
to to want to change to thank you I
didn't so the picture is not pretty and
I'm about to make the picture even less
pretty because and when you look at a
failure it's easy to do I'm afraid when
you look at the failure that Copenhagen
looks like that it will be presenting us
or the green wash efforts what does it
mean on the ground what does it mean to
communities what does it mean to water
scarcity and the region that I come from
the fertile crescent of the Middle East
and is very very very very worried as to
how climate change will act as a threat
multiplier for ready
water scarce part of the world that will
likely lead to even more animosity and
more conflict when we look at at the
models and presented on rainfall and on
recharger of aquifers due to changes in
the climate and we see increased
dramatic reductions both in quantities
of water quantities of the amounts of
precipitation that falls in the eastern
Mediterranean coast Jordan Palestine
Israel Syria Lebanon as areas that were
focused on but even more importantly the
way that the rain will fall and rather
than a week of several rain events one
dramatic rain event that will lead to a
tolerant to a flood basically and allows
the water to rush off to the sea and not
recharging the groundwater the most
important source of water you know very
dry part of the world is group an excuse
Me's groundwater and not surface water
and climate change threatens according
to some of the models to decrease
recharge of ground water for up to
seventy percent and also the rising sea
level of the Mediterranean threatens the
ground order again because of seed
seawater intrusion into the groundwater
the groundwater of the coastal aquifer
shared by Israel and Palestine and
rising water levels of the Nile Delta
flooding large sections of the Nile a
half a meter rise causes some three
million Egyptians to lose their homes to
lose their livelihoods a meter rise is
somewhere between six to eight million
Egyptians will lose their homes in their
livelihoods what does increased water
scarcity mean as as
political insecurity or increased
insecurity well it makes it so much more
difficult to reach peace agreements and
where peace agreements don't exist visa
V Israel and Syria Israel and Lebanon
the ritani River currently flows into
the Mediterranean predictions of climate
change present models where the lethani
will no longer flow the returnee in
Lebanon will no longer flow into the
Mediterranean there'll be not enough
water rising sea levels means that
Palestinians in Gaza who are already
drinking water unfit for human
consumption because of over extraction
because they denied other sources of
water and we'll have even worse water to
drink because of the increased
salinization of that water with the rise
of the Mediterranean and less
precipitation less groundwater means
that economies in Palestine and Jordan
that are more dependent on agriculture
some thirty percent of GDP for Palestine
comes from agriculture for Palestinians
and that's largely dependent on rain-fed
agriculture well that goes and creating
more instability in Palestine for Jordan
although its contribution to GDP and
agriculture is not so significant it's
very important for the stability of the
kingdom and that's where the loyalty
base of King Abdullah comes from it
comes from the rural communities that
are all dependent on the ground water
and the rainfall the climate change is
going to dramatically decrease so a real
threat to water security and to
implications not only for our own part
of the world but globally because as
we've seen that increased that continued
insecurity and hostility and violence
and animosity in the Middle East
so alarmingly spreads to the rest of the
world and the answer for the wealthier
communities and in this case the answer
for Israel is increased desalination but
that's all available only for rich
countries and of course that leads to
the burning of more fossil fuels because
it's all involving burning of either gas
coal or oil and that leads to greater
air pollution and increased co2
emissions this issue of climate change
is finally an issue that you can't blame
at least and the eastern Mediterranean
countries for world conflict and this is
an issue that leadership is required
from you from you here and this is an
issue that scares Israelis and
Palestinians and uranians together just
last weekend for the 350 event Jordanian
youth did the number three on their
shores of the Dead Sea Palestinian youth
did the number five on their shores of
the Dead Sea and Israeli youth the
number zero an aerial photography
combined at all to 350 and you might
have seen it on CNN and so it has led to
some level of cooperation but largely at
least the non oil-producing part of the
Middle East is not to blame and can't do
anything about the implications of
climate change it's up to you and that's
why Copenhagen and post Copenhagen is so
crucial that leadership be shown by the
developing States and by some of the
large underdeveloped States thank you
didn't thank you very much Vince take it
away thank you when done asked me to
speak and speak on behalf of Asia I felt
like wait a minute I should have
probably a Chinese on one side and an
Indian on the other side to back me up
to represent Asia but what I like to do
is maybe talk about first how it impacts
climate changes and
sure as far as the Philippines and then
I want to go on a Google Earth view of
where things stand on the road to
Copenhagen you probably have read all
the newspaper our stories about the
massive typhoons we've had and the
Philippines lately and that was really
as an outcome of a very unusually hot
summer early this year which has bred
these super typhoons in the western
Pacific and now they're just roaring
down the typhoon alley of towards the
Philippines Hong Kong and Taiwan that
has brought the issue of climate change
to the forefront of each and every
filipino when WWF Philippines in early
this year was debating how do we bring
the topic of time it changed the to the
public we were very cautious in coming
up with predictions from sea level rise
of maybe two meters four meters we
didn't want to scare the public but when
these super typhoons just passed through
in september-october we saw rainfall of
two meters in a week where we saw flood
waters rise by eight to ten meters in in
less than 24 hours so immediately
climate change is in the forefront of
every Filipino consciousness about a
week or two ago the president world
while I fun Jim leap came to the
Philippines and we call them the
President on how should we somewhat make
Copenhagen more of a success and death
of a failure I actually off off the
believe us then that I think we're not
going to expect much this December but
nonetheless you you don't give up and
you go for a fighting chance till the
last second so we spoke to the president
president arroyo on my former boss and
she said to us wait wait a minute the
Philippines we're not an issue here
we're a climate taker not a climate
maker the Philippines has passed some
very progressive biofuels law requiring
blending of biofuels in our diesel and
gasoline last year we pass a landmark
renewable energy law that requires
feed-in tariffs and renewable portfolio
standards to increase our level of
renewable power mix which is currently
today is about thirty thirty four
percent of our powers from renewable
which is actually not bad compared to
our neighboring countries that are oil
exporting countries so we're actually
they're already in the forefront and
certainly we want to see a climate
treaty by december this year but the
philippines is not a dealmaker we are
not a pivotal decision voice in
copenhagen and that's where i want to
now lead you to a slide that i like to
show you sasha knows me that every time
i've been here so we'll fellow i always
have a powerpoint presentation but i
have one slide if i could just ask my
panelists to look at their arm and turn
around and show you a slide in my maid
of WWF view of the world as far as
perhaps sometime in october of the
likelihood of where we see a climate
treaty I like this slide because 1 i'm
speaking in a university environment so
we all love this matrices and this is a
slide on one axis you have what we call
more supportive in other words they're
in favor of a climate treaty and down
the other axis in this down below you
have perhaps what we call less
supportive of a climate treaty the
horizontal axis talks about less
powerful states the alliance of small
island states on the leftmost corner
countries like the maldives which i'm
sure you read recently has had a cabinet
meeting on the water to drive the point
of sea level rise or the scandinavian
what we call climate leaders africa the
progressive g77 of which the philippines
is part of and then on the other side
and the upper right of course is what we
call the progressive EU that by germany
that sasha has stopped
but we have what we call in this sort of
purple bubble what we call the core
dealmakers a climate treaty cannot
happen without the role of the EU China
Japan India in the USS illustrated by
this column but recent pronunciations
have shown that there's some movement in
this map now you see you Sasha perhaps
being less supportive of climate change
now you'll argue with me that's not true
that Germany is going to speak loud in
Washington DC but because of the global
financial crisis there is some concern
perhaps from Italy that maybe we
shouldn't be as aggressive in the
reduction that we will mandate in a post
Kyoto Protocol so we see slight the
dropping of support from the EU with the
Obama election of course we now see a
more support coming from the United
States and I think it's a question of
timing I think there's a question of way
too much on the agenda that registered
to the gender whether it's healthcare
Afghanistan or the climate 3d
and with the recent election of hatami
the Prime Minister of Japan I think he's
come out perhaps a little bit ahead of
his electorate in being more Pro towards
the climate 3d here and oops just me
they just accidentally go backwards I
didn't mean that he just got recently
elected he'll be around and I think
recent propagations from India seems to
signal that they're now willing to
actually look at some form of but with a
lot of preconditions a lot of
negotiating maximum Maxima minima stance
oops and and and I think the question
here is we cannot reach the deal without
the united states that is absolutely the
fact of life Anna sasha mentioned the
next important meeting of leaders is the
apec summit in November 1416 it's in
Singapore the US will be there Australia
will be there China will be there Mexico
Russia and our message to our President
President royal when we called in her
actually last sunday is that the members
of APEC need to speak loud and we have
only one audience President Obama that
we are behind were moving into this so
that when it comes back mid-november
hopefully they'll be sub movement maybe
that's wishful thinking in the logistic
if we think he has three fourths of
Congress behind it half lower house and
half of the Senate the Democratic side
but I think with a 60 / 60 volts in the
Democrats I think that's not something
that could be taken for granted because
we have to have the moderate Democrats
in buying into this there's been some
talk that perhaps the India and China my
prepared to have a regional 3d there was
some talk last week about China
in India coming signing a regional MOU I
think that's all just negotiating
posture leading up to Copenhagen and I
think the key question is whether or not
we're going to have representation on
the head of state level in Copenhagen
are they going to show up we know that
President Obama went all the way to was
it Copenhagen for the Olympics and kind
of expose himself perhaps that Chicago
didn't quite make it in the first round
to the Olympic venue and maybe now he
has to think twice but I think unless he
goes we're not going to find a deal so I
think I want to end my little
contribution and leave it to a Q&A thank
you dance for a very vivid demonstration
of the complexity here all right it's
your opportunity to add your perspective
or ask a question starting the back
Russia Indonesia Mexico in South Africa
they're all federal countries and you
all talk as if we lived in this realist
world of essentially so of these these
unitary States and what we miss here is
that this is not a collective action
problem at a realist national level that
the countries of the key deal player are
deal breakers in field makers here all
countries with strong sub-national
governments some of which are among the
most progressive in the world where the
guards to climate regulation some of
which are the most sort of behind with
regards to climate regulation and so I
think as long as we keep thinking of the
world in terms of 192 states that can
somehow sign a deal but we all know that
in the united states the federal
government has relatively little leeway
without getting the states on board
we're not going to be getting far and so
i'm not sure whether the level of
discussion that we're having on the
panel is really going to help us solve
the fundamental collective action and i
mix that I work here anyone want to
comment well just just for the sake of
discussion I think this is actually not
true what do you say there is obviously
a big difference in the u.s. between
well the level of emissions also the
level of policy in California as opposed
to let's say Texas and I don't want to
pick on taxes i could pick other states
too but the the key policy framework is
being sat in Washington both
domestically you are especially for
issues like international cooperation
and the that is what we had did
experience in the last eight years that
there was well everyone was obviously
focusing on what was happening in the
states even international cooperation
was happening was focusing on that kind
of things Germany's foreign minister was
traveling to california visiting mr.
Schwarzenegger because there was no one
in Washington talk to but at the end of
the day those things don't really well
change the game and the game changing
decisions have to be made in the
national capitals in Washington and in
Moscow and in Beijing
it's also not the case for Australia
although it's a federation it's the
federal government that signs
international treaties and to make the
commitment it's not reliant it's not
like the u.s. system of depending on the
states so it does differ from place to
place and that's not the case also in
Australia although i think in defense of
the question in the united states it's
not the states can themselves fix the
problem on their own they won't they
can't but the political dynamic which
means they send certain senators to
Washington who are not disposed toward a
treaty is the fundamental issue here and
then some all that good wishing for
Obama won't get us very far if we are at
59 votes in the Senate and you point out
there 60 Democrats but let's subtract 18
Cole state Democrats from that total and
then start counting up again and that's
the political difficulty I think very
tough to get that Mac to work another
question comment please it was a
microphone coming and if you can hold
just one second will make sure to record
you for posterity thank you very much
for coming here today and I'd like to
what it is that has been going on a mon
morning is the fact this is that all of
the numbers that we're talking about the
money that's going to be paying for the
the renewable energy the cap and trade
it's all based upon how it is that we
were able to fund and by our way into
this problem in the beginning so how do
you propose looking into the future the
economies and how it is that we will buy
our way out of this predicament that we
have because we can't be buying stuff
producing stuff the way that we have in
the past yeah i mean i don't know that
i've got i don't know that i've got a
definitive night i certainly don't have
a definitive answer that what i would
say is is is I you taint Nick stearns
report in 2007 suggesting that 450
billion US dollars of have spend one
percent of global gdp could go
way towards you know carbon proofing the
planet and the amount of rigor and
cross-examination has been put in his
direction and amount of questioning
that's gone on as to as to where that
money would come from and you then
contrast that with the kind of back of
the envelope let's let's rescue everyone
we possibly can bankers and automotive
companies and that sort of thing
slightly willy nilly with with arguably
not anywhere near the same level of due
diligence applied to the tune of perhaps
ten ten point eight trillion I think the
BBC reported the other day that the
total cost of recession busting measures
as a global figure and you can question
these figures but the order of magnitude
I think speaks for itself you know 20
times the kind of spend that nyx turn
was was recommending we spend to try and
to try and mitigate and it leaves you a
little bit cold no pun intended that one
set of values get gets applied to one
side of the equation and a completely
different one gets applied to the other
and just to add to that there is the 800
billion dollars worth of potential
revenue from the sale of the permits
that the United States be will be
putting in play one can question whether
the existing legislative proposals that
give 80-plus percent of that away
without auctioning it are in fact the
right strategy recognizing that there
will be substantial investments required
to make a different energy future
succeed other questions comments way
over on the side hi I think one of the
issues that may be negotiated the
dealing with now is a question of what
legal form that whatever deal in
Copenhagen takes you know if it going to
be a treaty kind of like the Kyoto
Protocol that has go back and be
ratified or could it be maybe something
else maybe a cop decision that it's
different I would not have to go back
and be ratified and I wonder you know
maybe you could talk about the pros and
cons of those different options and
maybe I'd be interested also and how it
would play in Washington if whatever
deal didn't have to go back and get
ratify Oh Sasha
well the thing is it has to be a legally
binding treaty and for the simple reason
that everything else will just not
consider to be binding and people will
just not just the other countries that
they do what they claim they do it's not
legally binding and one of the problems
that we're having in those negotiations
is that there is a lot of miss just
because well where you go back to Kyoto
there is well not all developed
countries ratified the Kyoto Protocol
although they signed it not all the
countries that ratified the Kyoto
Protocol well oh it achieved the
commitments they undertook and the
anything that is not legally binding we
just not cut it because this is
otherwise it will just be another of
those non-binding declarations that you
have in a lot of people a lot of areas
of international law well by like
declarations the Human Rights Council
passes that no one no one cares about so
we need a legally binding agreement it's
an interesting question whether we need
exactly the same we have a we are in
Kyoto probably not the US has made clear
they and have a different kind of
setting they probably also show a way of
the word because it carries hi-
symbolism in certain circles in this
country but it's also clear that the sum
of the political deals made in Kyoto are
unavoidable that there is a
differentiation for example between the
commitments developed with developing
countries also that the lead character
of the commitments for developed
countries is different than the one for
developing countries and that kind of
things and for some issues for example
for things like emission trading or the
Clean Development Mechanism but
everywhere where commodities are shifted
back and forth there are worth money you
need a legal framework because otherwise
you do not guarantee the the economic
worth of those assets and here see the
guy who's an expert in that I've been
making a lot of money with that I can
only talk about
I've not found a way to become rich now
you need you need a legally binding to
make it stick that's and it's that means
it's going to be years even if you know
where Lucky's an agreement is made in
December it'll probably will take
several years before everyone it becomes
I think your toe brought the fall on it
became effective early 2005 that's 20
years after that before it even becomes
effective another question right here I
think her question was also talking
about it being the cop decision as
possibly being an alternate mechanism
for actually getting a treaty past given
that I hear the word legally binding
tossed around a lot but I'm not really
sure that I understand what it means I
mean with Kyoto if people who didn't
like Canada of people who didn't
actually do what they were supposed to
do if there's no mechanism for
penalizing them then you know even if
Kyoto is our paragon of legal binding
pneus what does that mean and what would
it mean in you know in this sort of
post-2012 regime even if we had
something like Kyoto we had no
compliance mechanism let me answer as a
law professor you're all looking this
way um I think you're going to have to
take several law courses to get the full
level of detail necessary to think this
through so I won't try to give a
definitive answer except to say that
international law is a much softer law
than domestic law there is no structure
of police force out there to take
countries to the dock if they don't
fulfill their obligations and it's a
much it requires a much greater level of
creativity to really set up a structure
that convinces people that they should
adhere to whatever commitments they've
made because it's in effect well not
fully you know binding on them you know
you have to convince them rather than
harass them into fulfilling their
obligation
and you know there is just one of their
nuance here which those who watch the
u.s. process should just be aware of and
that is if it's in the form of a treaty
it actually takes 67 votes in the Senate
to get adopted so watch I think for the
u.s. to try and get this in the
structure of an executive legislative
agreement that requires only a majority
vote of both the house in the Senate as
opposed to 67 votes in just the Senate
but i do think with the rest of the
panel that it's very hard to get the
kind of financial commitment behind the
effort without there being true legally
binding obligations in the strongest
possible sense that it's available in
international law and that's why I think
we have to anticipate that there won't
be some observation of the parties or
alternative decision taken in Copenhagen
but rather a delay leading to a
full-blown agreement at some point down
the line I think by the way it is
uncertain whether leaving get done in
the six to 12 months that sasha is
hoping for because once the Obama
administration comes back from
Copenhagen and once they have their
health care proposal through despite the
bat very significant hopes of the
environmental community that that means
climate change is teed up next it will
not be the new administration's agenda
it going into the new year will center
on jobs and trying to ensure a better
economic picture going into the midterm
november two thousand ten elections so i
think this is going to take you know
many months all of 2010 more or less and
quite probably spilling over to 2011 to
get the US in a position to step up and
commits to real action that domestically
that is the necessary foundation on
which an international agreement gets
made and i think the consensus around
the need to get the u.s. locked down
domestically is quite strong here quite
striking please
we've seen a lot of movement here in the
US with the many corporations and the US
Chamber of Commerce which has been kind
of interesting and there's a lot of
discussion prior to Copenhagen about
policy mechanisms and governments is
there any value in committee of people
who are working on this to try to bring
global corporations and even in State
corporations to take aside and to get
them to align themselves one way or the
other regarding climate change in fact
they tend to be the ones that are
influencing our senators our legislative
bodies and perhaps really pushing the
corporate community not just people who
are in alternative energy for instance
but businesses hate uncertainty and a
lot of corporations I would think would
like to see something is ratified any of
you want to talk about the corporate
role here no particularly now very well
in fact the corporate role is really on
the domestic level I think this is the
point the business sector has to make in
a country like the you like the u.s.
that whatever the decision is there
there needs to make a decision on the
future framework the future framework on
the emission regime and internationally
I do not necessarily think if there is a
business leaders council in parallel to
Copenhagen that the copenhagen summit a
that anyone would
attention because people would pay
attention to what governments are
talking about this is us to place for
governments but on the national level
without support of business for a change
in well basically managing the energy
sector nothing will happen okay and I do
think in the domestic us situation you
have a number of companies that have
stepped up a summum in a structured way
through the US Climate Action
Partnership to say that the time for
binding commitments has come this by the
way is a stark contrast to a good bit at
the last 20 years history in this field
when I was negotiating the framework
convention on climate change in 1992 I
went all around the country looking for
companies that would step up and say
time to do a deal should get going on
climate change and outside of a few
alternative energy companies very tough
going the only big company in the world
only big company in the US that was
willing to say anything positive about
the prospect of addressing climate
change was Enron which as we know did
not come to a good end nor did the
leader who was willing to talk Ken Lay
so we have come a good distance in this
country and I think that does make the
politics easier because you've got a
business community that is I think one
could argue divided but probably leaning
towards predictability in wanting a
clear path forward can I just say yeah
very very quickly it's probably not
specifically answering your question but
it does highlight the idea the need for
some sort of institutional continuity
between policy level directives and what
actually happens on the ground and what
I was saying about and what I think is
one of the biggest stumbling blocks for
Copenhagen really is for the developing
countries to take countries like the you
come up on a UK bashing mission hibbett
to take them seriously when in 2007 they
have an energy security white paper that
says you know one of the key goals for
the next few years is to maximize and
you know oil and gas production from the
North Sea for our energy security and
yet on the other side of the coin you
have this this statement about trying to
reduce co2 emissions and the same thing
applies at
a policy level when compared to the
actual actions of industry on the ground
and until you have some sort of real
institutional consistency rather than
just politicians making noises you're
not really going to get proper update
from developing countries question in
the back great well as you were just
noting their hugely divergent interests
between developing nations and developed
nations today so what are the prospects
you think of trying to maybe have two
levels of negotiations between these two
sets of countries and as a corollary to
that what kinds of concessions and sort
of technology transfers or whatever to
develop countries need to make to get
developed and developing nations on
board I think I think one thing that
needs to happen is there needs to be an
acceptance on the part of developed
countries that developing countries need
to emit a certain amount of carbon to
lift their populations out of the
situation it's a poverty so in the case
of India an idea that's been tabled is
that they require a kind of an allowance
of perhaps two tonnes per head for each
person that's on below the poverty line
it's what they called the calm to avoid
scenario they're saying look you know we
want to stick to these these carbon
minutes but we we are duty-bound to
develop our economy to bring these
people out of the situation of rural
poverty help us out here and the figure
that's being tabled is two tonnes per
per person who's on less than a dollar
25 us a day and I think that's a sort of
a reasonable stance you can take it all
the way through to the extreme version
of that of that situation we're under
kind of strict liability Africa feels it
knows virtually nothing in fact you
should be being compensated for the
drought situations and the climate
change they're experiencing as a result
of developed countries having having
enjoyed 250 years of development and you
know I don't have a particular position
on that but I do think there needs to be
some acceptance of this can't avoid
scenario there and an allowance mate men
together
want to add some work well it's that's
the point of India which is sort of
allow us to have so much emission per
capita China looks slightly differently
allow us to grow an economy but we're
willing to reduce the growth of emission
below the economic growth so you got two
different models one is a emission per
capita for the engine position and the
Chinese position is that ok will support
this climate treaty but will grow don't
cap us but will grow but lower than our
economic growth so and again you need
both countries to make a deal stick
locally Sasha and by the way the reason
behind us is that the average Chinese
emissions per capita emissions happen to
be exactly the average emissions on a
planetary scale so China has nothing to
grow anymore india house and this is the
point i don't think it makes NC more to
talk about developing countries they are
very different countries good way very
different starting points and very
different interests there the African
countries are interesting adaptation
only and their missions are not
significant at all there some countries
who have specific interest when it comes
to forest the trophy to forest countries
in the Congo basins of the Amazon basin
Southeast Asia and then there are the
the what is being classically perceived
as developing countries in here china
and the light which are very different
in china for example the orig emission
of a of an inhabitant of beijing or
shanghai is the same cup per capita
level as the average mission of an
inhabitant of Paris or Berlin the
overall emission of China are different
because they are big regional
differences so that is also that
something that has has to be taken into
account in fact one of the most damaging
things in international negotiations not
only in the calamity robot in the trade
area in human rights and so on is that
this artificial separation between
developed and developing countries in
this grouping of g77 that aggregates
countries that are extremely different
from
in a father to Singapore under this the
setting of developing countries and it's
perfectly understandable why this this
is still being kept up their political
interest especially of the ritual
developing countries to be treated like
like poor countries meaningless soft
clothes but it's not productive anymore
and by the way there there are two
conversations taking taken place or have
to take place at the APEC country the
one is the water mr. Obama basically
telling him you have a certain
responsibility here however difficult
you have situation at home might be but
the other also has to take place
probably between the Europeans and the
big emerging economies to tell them well
it's all all well and fine that there is
a differentiation between developed and
developing countries but you are not
that underdeveloped as you were 15 years
ago so just to add on that the question
premise what is the developed world
going to do for the developing world and
I would say it's an equally important
question flowing the other way as sasha
is suggesting and in the US political
dynamic i promise you there is no deal
at any point ever unless the major
developing countries have committed to
binding emissions controls and as sasha
said it doesn't mean that they're going
to go down but they have to commit to a
reduced trajectory of growth and that is
fundamental to getting anything close to
a majority in the US House and the US
Senate so we are going to have to see a
revitalization of the principle that's
been at the heart of every past global
environmental cooperation effort the
principle of common but differentiated
responsibilities common meaning every
country signs up no one's sitting on the
sidelines no one to use the economics
term free-riding differentiated
responsibilities meaning that there'll
be quite a wide variation between what
burkina faso's asked to do what
beijing's asked to do and what the US or
Europe would be asked to do another
question yes right here
so I think all the leaders in the world
yeah they're willing to take the lead to
help with a global climate change but
why they don't do is it's because every
country has its own difficulties say a
lot of countries don't have very good
financial mechanism to trade a
commission permit so I think maybe if we
we still focusing on that that problem
are not going to be safe soft so I want
to raise a question on the 4g side I
want to know maybe this question goes
specially to Vincent how much do you
think the developed countries are
willing to pay for four countries in the
tropical reason to refer for
reforestation how much are developing
countries we need to develop co-develop
Oh like how much us will be willing to
pay for reverse station in Amazon Orion
Philippines I don't have a number for
that there's some of you do so we'll
actually I think we put this to Sasha
because it's the European Union that's
obstructing the bringing of forestry
into the next agreement the u.s. is
certainly ready to do it we've got other
issues we're not so ready to move on but
forest is not the stumbling block in the
US but the European Union is so I was
glad to hear you say forestry is
critical to the next agreement but
that's not the official position out of
Brussels Oh them that's that's actually
not true what do you think but the it's
what the U has been saying the you is in
favor of including forests into a future
or regime the EU is house attempts to
use the carbon market to finance forest
tropical forest deforestation reduction
and the reason behind that is that there
is a certain suspicions against well
well european or North American
countries buying cheap tropical forest
carbon offsets in developing countries
and by there there by depressing the
carbon price
and thereby while creating havoc to the
European carbon market so this is the
reason behind it there is also well I
think this mistrust or its market-based
mechanism has also grown as a
consequence of the financial crisis
where everyone has learned that there
are a lot of financial products out
there that we don't fully understand we
do not necessarily want to create new
ones and in fact my organization earth
has been a little bit of more optimistic
about the role of forest carbon but the
EU supports the inclusion of forests in
torrey regime and has in fact already
announced well well not announced but
the European Commission has already
proposed a significant chunk of money
for the next year's for the interim face
Vince has already mentioned even if we
get an agreement in the next one to two
years there will be a ratification fifth
period so for the next five years or so
we also need something we also need some
interim financial mechanism to support
well capacity building technology
transfer climate change adaptation and
tropical tropical deforestation and that
all has to come from public households
so I ve you in a way of the mechanism to
generate that money through auctioning
to part of the auction revenue from the
emission trading system I hope the u.s.
system will also for see that by the way
even all the permits away yeah I think
they're all the permits be given away to
the coal interest here yeah yeah I
actually also fear that will happen i
had a conversation I'm just mentioning
that because this is your job to do to
take care of when the next weeks and
months the conversation last week in
Washington with someone that you know
well who was pretty high up in the I
tell you later was pretty high up in the
republican party hierarchy and who who
basically told me there will be a deal
on cap and trade with moderate
Republicans and the deal is the
following three things will have to
happen subsidies for nuclear subsidies
for the agricultural sector and no
auctioning in the first years of the
Kevin
system this is the deal it's not a good
deal especially not the latter because
said to my knowledge the US has a
significant household deficit and I
don't think that those financial
transfers will Pete be paid out of the
general budget we need some new sources
of financing the only one I see is the
carbon market good point here I'm
wondering if you all think that a
Copenhagen should really just be
focusing on production of carbon
emissions or if there's any place in the
discussion we're talking about adapting
to negative effects of climate change
actually happening well I think the new
buzzword now is other patients for now
mitigation is for the future and for a
lot of those countries that are
vulnerable adaptation is important so I
think you're still going to see
adaptation as part of the agreement in
not just mitigation yeah and
particularly for the less developed
countries that's clearly a priority that
financing for adaptation be integrated
into any agreement that comes out that's
the the major demand of the developing
countries and I would like to highlight
while we talk about you know the
responsibility of the state's be it a
national or federal and how about the
the responsibility of us as individuals
and are we really doing enough in the
choices that we make when using our
purchasing power
in raising our voice at the 350 event in
washington DC on saturday there were
maybe 250 people in brooklyn bridge
there are 400 people it's not a very
loud voice that's not a very effective
way of telling members of Congress here
in the US that this is an issue that the
American public is worried about well
I'm afraid we are out of time but please
join me in thanking our speakers and
then we will continue the conversation
more informally outside